les occidentaux ne devrait-il pas
définir une porte de sortie politique
accepte pas acceptable pour les
ukrainiens et russes en attendant le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
lui s'est félicité d'une approche
fondamentalement différente de moscou
dans les récents pourparlers avec qui
elle son écoute le président et
craignant
un groupe de négociateurs ukrainiens et
russes
discuter de diverses questions
actuellement
ils ont commencé à parler de quelque
chose et pas seulement à lancer des
ultimatums
je pense qu'il s'agit d'une approche
fondamentalement différente
il devrait toujours en être ainsi
je pense aussi que cette discussion
n'inclut pas suffisamment de partenaires
et de dirigeants occidentaux
car si nous parlons des garanties de
sécurité de notre état il est impossible
de faire confiance à la russie